[Music]
so David Beckham has a Netflix
documentary out where it's a bit of a
tell all oh all the skeletons in his
closet and then when we finally got
under the juicy bit they kind of skirted
around what went on there but luckily
for you lot you've got me to figure it
out for you if you're not smart like me
and I remember at the time thinking
bloody hell if a perfect man like David
Beckham cheats then what hope are the
rest of us Gremlins got why even try I
could have been a good man if it wasn't
for you Dave so I guess the question is
why did David Beckham cheat he had it
all the pop star wife beautiful kids an
amazing football career well when you
watch the documentary it's pretty
obvious I mean he did have it all like
him and Victoria got on like a house on
fire from early on in the documentary
you can see they really did love each
other it wasn't like oh let's just get
together because you're a pop star and
I'm a footballer I'll give her credit
like she really added value to his brand
and helped him develop the Beckham brand
she's a very smart woman and they both
loved detention but if there's one thing
that is quite clear from early on it's
that David Beckham needed Victoria
Beckham more than she needed him like
she needed him because her Talent was
almost non-existent and her irrelevant
pop career was going to crash and burn
at any minute but from an emotional
level he really needed her support and
he was glued to her they were up on the
pH until 3 in the morning when he went
through being what wasn't really called
cancelled then but it was cancelled he
[__] up on the football pitch and
everyone hated him for it she was his
support and she was actually really good
at that do you think you could say all
that again but without trashing her
career it's not as funny then is it
sorry he's oh you know women oh they do
love to get their input in can you not
say the truth no that's how we do this
on this channel you'll hear lesser here
from now one you'll be going down to
Victoria Beckham Road soon love so they
have a couple of kids called him uh
Brooklyn after where they conceived him
so if you're ever in Brooklyn you know
that it's not just famous for Notorious
BIG JZ but also the Becks had a quickly
there once so after the kids are born
brand Beckham has almost become too much
for Manchester United to even contain
and he then moves to the most star
studed football site in World football
in Real Madrid and he says to Victoria
pick your house get it all ready we're
going to move there let's plan for the
long term and by that point in the
documentary Victoria doesn't seem to be
in the same frame of mind she isn't
glued to him she's now looking after the
kids and trying to reinvent her pop
career and that was a waste of time was
it got to go and record a single with
Kane Bowers that was a good idea was it
and Victoria doesn't move to Madrid with
him now this is someone who throughout
the series has craved her attention and
has needed to have his handheld for
strength because he isn't that strong
and he's doing really daunting things
like trying to compete for a place
against some of the best players in
World football in a new country in a new
side she allows him to go to Madrid
alone have you ever been to Spain any
chance let me tell you it's a catwalk
everywhere I went to Germany I could
have walked miles before I even met a
five out of 10 in Barcelona they've got
tens working at McDonald's they're
everywhere fat asses and big eyes all
over the place if you're a woman and
your man says he's going to Spain for a
holiday even for a week be worried you
can fall in love at a checkout over
there let alone David Beckham this man
was the most handsome Sportsman in World
football there he is such a handsome man
honestly any picture you want you oh
this will keep me going for hours if I
don't stop he was a very handsome man in
Spain it's a bad combination and she's
like it's all right we're fine I've got
two kids with you I don't have to make
any I don't have to worry do you know
like when they say like he's president
she's the first lady what they really
mean is she's got to be the first lady
on her knees the minute he gets excited
you got to be there when Rebecca Lou
approached she should have been down
there already like I've got this yeah
leave it shouldn't have had the
opportunity but no David twiddling his
thumbs in Madrid being handsome as [__]
one of the best paid athletes in World
football and he's just wandering around
there lonely I'm not saying he should
have
cheated but I understand I know women
you hate to hear this sort of [__]
because it's always the man's fault and
generally it can't be right I've done it
myself I was a piece of [__] sometimes
men are just pieces of [__] I get it but
in this case through this entire
documentary all he wanted was to be with
her she didn't go with him to his new
place of business what did you think was
going to happen David Beckham the fact
that he wasn't already cheating on you
means he was a great guy it was getting
thrown at him worse than Drake gets it
it was bad he was probably having to
like really push women away from him and
he maintained a relationship for a long
time and you know how you know this is
true is that the minute it comes out
Victoria's straight over there
immediately oh now I'm moving in oh
really well then glad you got that
figured out I'm not saying he should
have done it but I understand to expect
a David Beckham to be faithful is
straight up insane anyway but to expect
them to do it when you're not giving him
any sex that's a mental you [__] up
Victoria I'm sorry now let's talk about
the woman who we actually had the affair
with was it worth it it's never worth it
Lads well sometimes is but generally you
shouldn't do it so this was Victoria at
the time you know she was very quite
serious and she didn't come across as
fun loving she wasn't the fun one
whereas Rebecca l i mean that's a bit of
fun is it she's got the naughtiest eyes
and if you're a lonely man in Spain and
she's looking at you like that and
you're like it's been months I'm sick of
wanking you're David Beckham and you're
wanking in Madrid what the hell is she
thinking genuinely I keep coming back to
this she's mental for that she was a
paer as well and that's a good
combination she's a bit naughty and
she's organized as a man that'll get you
every time so I can see why this would
have happened right she's out with the
football team she's a PA she's there to
assist you I'm sure she was happy to
help with everything he needed so once
Rebecca lose realized she wasn't going
to be the one and she was just a little
side piece she decides to ruin his life
which has become sort of common practice
throughout the decades now hasn't it she
was one of the first at that a Pioneer
she led an industry of hoes credit to
her now as much as I think Victoria made
some mistakes she got complacent she
wasn't thinking right she paid that
price with her Mar being damaged by that
and as did David for his actions but
what really made it bad was this woman
went on national news and went through
the messages and everything like have
some shame it's bad enough you are a
cumrag like don't celebrate that crowner
15 minutes of fame here we go the
chemistry between David and I was so
strong that everyone was aware and
people weren't happy and that's that
personal validation that she's getting
off it of David Beckham was interested
me and everyone seeing it that's what
this is really about immediately that's
clear because I was being very
unprofessional and he's a married man oh
you love that you see the way she said
that he's a married man and yet he just
couldn't keep his eyes off of me what
will we do David I guess we'll have the
[__] I'm so sorry Dave this happens to
men though this is like so normal like
because our were dicks on thinking this
man was wanking in Madrid what are you
expecting this girl came up set between
us and we were chatting and laughing and
he just kept looking at me and then it
dawned on me that what he'd asked me um
and I did want to go back with him so
you know we just sort of gave each other
a look and a n of the head and paid the
bill and we left who paid the bill was
it you was it I doubt it so tell me
about the emotions you left the hotel
you presumably went home how did you
feel then yeah was very
breathless I exerted a lot of energy
riding David Beckham all night just to
be clear I was breathless I mean at
least you didn't see me [__] I was a bit
disappointed underwhelming if I'm honest
he certainly was a man of the match had
to finish myself off afterwards yeah I
got home and my mother said where have
you slept where you spent the night and
and she could just tell by the look of
my face she knew I didn't have to tell
her she knew I don't know why but this
is just so [__] funny like she knew I
didn't have to tell her she just knew
just by this I can tell she danced
around her mother's kitchen celebrating
we got it we did it she genuinely
thought she was getting David Beckham at
the end of this you silly woman J she
just said well I hope you being careful
I hope you don't get pregnant by that
multi-millionaire man and have a baby oh
that would be terrible wouldn't it I bet
you she was and lay on her back for half
an hour after the come went in I went to
visit him at his hotel room before a
match and I was very excited to see him
and it was literally in you know close
off get the action done and out within
sort of half an hour and I left there
feeling
absolutely I felt like a [__] I felt
really cheap this really explains why
David Beckham was so [__] at Real Madrid
this guy was exerting mad energy before
he even stepped foot on the pitch wow
David he did half an hour and then
another 90 minutes his stamina was
pretty good though I've got to give him
credit I felt like a [__] I thought
really cheap and I felt used I mean
she's entitled to feel how she felt but
like you were using him right you're
both using each other you know he's got
a match of 3:00 love unless he literally
finishes ins Sida and then he pulls his
Real Madrid shorts up he's like right
love got to go she's like oh I thought
we were going to grab dinner and have a
bit of a nah not a deal of big match on
I said I'm not I'm not even why am I why
am I doing this why am I putting myself
through this because emotionally I've
been through a lot she's acting like a
Burns victim she had a few cies with
David Beckham I've been through a lot
there was still feelings there I suppose
I adore him I still do she's literally
making his life so much worse in telling
everyone what happened between them and
then she's saying but but I adore him
you're literally putting him through the
worst period possible in public but I
adore him Psychopathic Behavior if you
really adore this man you wouldn't just
be destroying him right now publicly
that's mental the smile from her as
she's destroying his reputation no I
adore him I still
do
by the way if you're wondering why she's
doing the interview she got paid a f ton
to sell her story when this all happened
so does she adore him yeah but does she
adore him enough to not cash in on him
and ruin his life sadly no and that's
the tragedy people calling me a liar and
calling me calling me names and and
and you know and at the end of the day
these are the facts this is what
happened this is the truth and I
shouldn't be ashamed of it me and you be
ashamed of it should he have done it
absolutely not is he a piece of [__] for
it yeah but you knew what you were doing
there's no courtesy there for other
people's lives at all as much as you
know it's David Beckham's family she was
very aware of it they were the most
[__] famous family in England but
she's actually 20 years later started
commenting on it again now all of this
has been dug up got another chance a few
more minutes of fame have we so this is
Rebecca now just doing a bit of
sunbathing and uh since the story has
been Unearthed again people have been
spamming her with comments and she's
sort of had her say on it where someone
has said there's never been an
admittance that the story was true
someone else then commented well if it
wasn't true they would have sued up for
defamation and she responded to that
with a light remark and a prayer hands
Emoji she's now a yoga teacher it seems
with um a family of her own I think
maybe that's why she's barely
acknowledged it outside of that and
hopefully like she's grown beyond the
need for validation of being the side
piece of some celebrity 20 years ago and
keeps it classy and just moves theck on
so we've got multiple articles to choose
from here about Rebecca loose thanks to
ground news who are our sponsor today
shout out to them and they've got an
easy to use website and app to give you
different viewpoint on all of the latest
news not just Rebecca and why I love
this platform is it shines a light on
all of the media bias and actually holds
the media accountable by adding context
and transparency so this website will
Cate all of the stories about the news
that you're searching for and it'll tell
you who the Publishers are their
political bias and how factual their
reporting usually is so I search Rebecca
loose and David Beckham and you've got
140 new sources here uh three leaning
left four leaning right five centered
and this is two hours ago updated so
very current you've got 42% Central bias
distribution here and why I like this
feature is because when I'm talking to
use about something I want to know I've
got the full picture and I'm giving you
all of the information and not just what
I've plucked from one newspaper that
might just have the interest of the
person we're talking about at hand and
another reason why I like this is I just
get a list of information here that I
can jump from news article to news
article all there in one place on ground
news and we're also given a factuality
score from the historic reporting of the
new source itself so the independent has
a high factuality score Hollywood life
however mixed so less likely to trust
them and as you know I like to cover
some controversial stories and it's
important to have all of the information
like with the two pack story we did the
other day and that's why I'm glad to
have ground news back in the channel
appreciate it so if you want to check it
out for yourself go to ground.
newsg and you can sign up for free or
you can subscribe before October 30th
and you can get 30% off their unlimited
access Vantage plan as for the beckhams
it does seem that there was a major
change in their relationship post that
whole time where Victoria realized like
I'm not the main player here like he is
and I need to be there as a support for
him I credit her for that in actually
keeping the family together and not just
destroying it over that which would have
been a possibility overall I thought the
documentary was good if you haven't
watched it it's definitely worth a watch
in in terms of like the big characters
in his life the Manchester United
manager so Alex Ferguson and then all
the ups and downs throughout his career
are in there and especially the
relationship with his dad was fantastic
so I do recommend it but I did just want
to comment on this for a bit of fun let
me know how you've seen the situation in
the comments below like the video don't
forget to subscribe to the true Jordy
YouTube channel thanks for watching and
I'll see you
later